,
Marie-Ève Bédard.
flement)
- Le réveil a été brutal à Kiev.
e de missiles s'est
abattue en plein coeur de la
capitale. Depuis plusieurs mois,
bercés pbercés pbercés pbercés t
de sécurité. La torpeur
matinale s'est vit
transformée en cau
pour beaucoup d'entre eux.
Dans les parcs, sur un pontpiéte
du travail, pendant près
de cinq heures, ils ont
cherché à tromper
Olena pensait avoir fui
le danger en quittant la ville
occupée en colèreen colèreen cot
des bâtards, dit-elle, c'est ça,
ils veulent détruire notre
peuple, nos infrastructures,
tout. Je suis vraiment fâchée."
L'illusion de sécurité a volé
en éclats, les stations de métro
n se donne
un peu de courage en fredonnant
des airs patriotiques.
Selon la défense ukrainienne,
l'armée russe a la
de 80 missiles sur l'Ukraine
depuis les airs, la mer
et la terre. Des dizainesdes drs
kamikazes, ont aussi été
déployés sur tout le pays.
Lviv, touest, largement
épargnée par des combats
lointains, s'est retrouvée sous
les tirs. Dnipro, té secouée
par des explosions meurtrières.
Zaporijia, sa populationncore
depuis trois jours.
Au-delà des morts et
des blessés, des civils ciblése,
les infrastructures énergétiques
du pays ont été lourdement
endommag
et d'élencore ce soir.
Certaines presque entièrement.
L'Internet ne fonctionne pas
dans bien des régions.
Pour pallier le stress imposé
par les attaques sur son résidé
e fin à ses exportations
d'électricité vers l'Europe
a été clair. "Il est temps pour
l'Ukraine de rendre des comptes
pour l'explosion sur le pont qui
une humiune humiune humiune hum.
"Par ses actions, le régime
s'est de facto aligné
avec les formations terroristes
internationales, avec les
groupes les plus osser de tels s
réponse t
plus possible."
Le président russe promet
des répl sévères
en cas de nouvelles attaques
ukrainiennes contre la Russie.
que jamais sur l'appui de son
homologue Alexander Loukachenko.
Le président du Bélarus,
qui avait jusqu'ici résistésion,
a annoncé un retour massif
de soldats russes au Bélarus.Leé
les attaques multiples d'actes
terroristes, une dure journée
pour sonà ses concitoyens.
"Ils cherchent à semerla paniqu.
Ils veulent détruirergétique.
Ils sont désespérés",
a-t-il dit.
"C'est une escalade inacceptable
de la guerre", selon lere générs
unies, António Guterres."ont tos
d'un crime de guerre",
selon l'Union européenne.
(sirènes et alarmes)interviennet
alors que la Russie enchaîne les
revers et les déco
le début de septembre en Ukraine
perdant du terrain dans le sud
comme dans le nord
Ici Marie-Ève Bédard, Radio-Cae